first of all you you made this movie
before a global health crisis
um what was it like seeing um
you know your movie coming out and then
knowing everything that is
that has happened
well either one of you david you want to
start no
uh well well i think for me there was
just no way that we could have foreseen
this happening i mean i mean uh i
gravitated towards the film because it
has universal
timeless themes around family connection
to looking after our planet i also loved
the idea of doing a film on this scale
who doesn't want to be in a film
directed in and starring george clooney
um
but you know we we finished the film
early february
all went home and by march we were all
being told not to leave the house
um because the world was was
seemingly ending it almost felt like and
then months later to then
see the film and see how prophetic the
film
was in terms of how prescient those
themes were gonna be for us
all going into this pandemic was
something that was just
shocking to be perfectly honest but but
thankfully things are not as dire
in real life well maybe they are i don't
know
but um but but certainly it's it's the
film proves to be a cautionary tale
and and something for us all to really
reflect on
yeah and felicity for you i mean you
you're working in this bubble of
creating a movie and then you come
out of it and then this is kind of all
going on what did that feel like for you
it was very very strange it was very
hard to be acting in an apocalyptic film
and then
find ourselves in an in a real
apocalyptic moment
uh it was it was definitely a little
scary uh but i did think
back and i thought i wonder how
convincing i was in my acting
of what it would be like to be in an
apocalyptic moment
as i was going through it myself but um
but yeah i mean none of us
could imagine just how relevant the film
would become um and let's hope it's also
a bit of a warning shot you know in
in the midnight sky the human race have
completely destroyed planet earth and
and let's hope
we we don't go that far yeah well let's
just say
your acting was phenomenal so you you
portrayed it very well and very it was
very real
it took your breath away for sure um you
had a director who is
you know a world-renowned actor um
i have asked everyone and i even asked
him
what was he like as a director what did
you think what's your critique david
what did what did you think
oh well you know that there's nothing to
criticize is the reality which is a
little bit annoying because i'd love to
be able to say to you he was
really really terrible um
but no he he is as affable
as personable and as talented
as as his work to date has
has shown um but on top of that
he's actually quite self-deprecating
he's someone who
really really cares about the audience
he wants to make films that they are
going to
identify with that they are going to
embrace you know
he has been very open with me about the
instances where films he has done hasn't
worked to the degree that he would like
and uh
and he takes it more personally than he
would care to admit
um and so you know getting a film right
doing the work in order to get it right
is something he takes very seriously
it's what he demands of the people
around him but
not in a sort of um dictatorial way
but he leads by example and and and that
is uh
it was just a wonderful thing to be
around him
love felicity how about you how was your
experience
yeah it was fascinating to watch i mean
obviously
someone who's been on hundreds of film
sets and
and television sets and and seeing how
he he operates was was really
interesting he likes you to come very
well prepared
he he trusts that you will do a lot of
your homework at home
um he likes the set to move very swiftly
i think he doesn't like it to get
too um sometimes it can get very
slow and people get tired and he likes
to keep their sense of pace
and that helps you as a performer
because you know that
when you do a take that everyone is
going to be absolutely focused so
so nothing is going to be missed um so
it's a very
it's a it's a very um actually a very
respectful way of working because it
respects people's time um and
he also just creates a really easy going
atmosphere
he's he's you know there's always an
element of being a little bit like oh
it's george clooney
you know what's he going to be like but
he's so
he is he's just very straightforward and
he's he's very earth
and it has a very very dry sense of
humor yeah he's not
sort of um he's not guarded at all he's
very very open
you